am I I mean I'll take it in more than
one way Adam 22. boo'd like Kev how you
doing I'm good man I can't complain
brother it's so crazy so yesterday we're
in my studio and I was like oh yeah
adam22 is coming on tomorrow I told uh
my producer and there was like this
random white dude in the studio
and he was like oh that's the guy right
who like let the dude [__] his wife
and I was like yeah and he asked he was
like wait you don't know who adam22 is
like otherwise he's like no like what
does he do yeah it does feel like that
there's a lot of people who just found
out about me from this which is it's
good for your business yeah I can't
complain how is the metrics changed in
terms of like just just like on a basic
level like let's say just your IG
I think I might have gained like 50 000
followers on on Instagram in like 60 or
70 on Twitter so just obviously that
doesn't like matter that much but it is
kind of indicative of oh okay there's a
lot of new eyeballs on me I'm curious
too because like I've seen obviously I I
just saw I think I just saw something on
Tick Tock Elena on why you guys chose
Jason love okay
um how long was you guys get married
yeah beautiful wedding was in Italy yeah
I love it looked crazy thank you and
then you guys appeared to have gone on
the most elaborate honeymoon family
vacation ever that is the most baller
[__] that we've ever done and it was
like a month right there was so much
money the nicest hotels ever I was like
just surrounded by Real Deal rich people
and how much did you drop in a month oh
probably six figures six figures on the
honeymoon yeah damn well I look like it
for sure it was [__] crazy
um and then you guys come back and it
feels like this kind of happens not
necessarily right away but it feels like
it almost happens
rather quickly we had been talking about
it basically since the beginning of the
year around January we did like a tick
tock with Jason love while we were at
the AVN I remember seeing that yeah and
it went crazy just us joking around
about the idea of her sleeping with a
guy so we already kind of had the idea
in our head and we had an idea of like
oh this is going to be viral like really
viral like this this might be just the
thing we need to sort of switch things
up and get rid get people really really
excited about it but we definitely
didn't know to what extent it was gonna
explode because she had a dollar amount
in her head that she told me at one
point and she has to date made like 50
50 times that the dollar amount meaning
how much money she thinks she would make
if she were to do that clip and yes and
then it's like
that times 50. whoa yeah like it was so
much bigger than we ever would have
dreamed well this is what I was gonna
say because like I would say this dude
like it feels like you guys really
planned this out in such a meticulous
way
and I feel like you've done such a great
job of like mastering the virality of
this moment I feel like I get
being a public Persona a lot more than I
ever did before and I feel like I get
going viral a lot more I feel a lot I I
it's ironic I feel like this gigantic
man putting dick in my [__] really
kinda like
helped me to like ReDiscover my voice
because I feel like so much less scared
or intimidated or or worried about what
I say on camera or whatever like after
the insanity of all this it just feels
like oh like you can say whatever [__]
you want at this point yeah like oh the
Soulja Boy said something about me on
live all right I'm gonna go off on
Soulja Boy like oh [__] Cowboy said
some lame [__] about me on podcast I'm
gonna go off on Cowboy like I'm just not
worried and it's like even even just
like my Instagram comments I was always
kind of combing that [__] and just like
restricting people who would say rude
[__] or whatever and at a certain point
during all this it just became like okay
what's the point of even looking at this
[__] who cares yeah I used to like wake
up and search my name on Twitter yeah
I've done it yeah that is not happening
anymore you can't do it anymore it's
over now it's over yeah it's pretty yeah
it's crazy well I was gonna say like
when you guys sat down and said okay
we're gonna do this did you map out the
promo did you map out okay we're gonna
do this this and this leading up up to
it and then afterwards we're going to do
this this and like how much of like some
of the content we saw was like
absolutely planned because a lot of it
felt like I was like oh you're like you
were you're really turning up and like
leaning into a lot of this most of it
wasn't like planned plan like in advance
it was mostly just me and her kind of
just talking about it and rolling with
the punches and just seeing what
happened and like you know you know like
I I had uh okay it was like there was
one day where
Jason love did an interview a couple
weeks ago and basically was like kind of
talking spicy being a little bit
disrespectful this was not planned this
was just him kind of not knowing how to
act or not knowing how to deal with the
the spotlight you know and I'm not gonna
lie like when I first seen it I had like
a day where I was kind of thinking about
it and I was annoyed and then like as I
was going to bed that night I just
pictured in my head me making a tick
tock in which I threatened him and
blacklisted him from my wife's vagina
okay and I was just laying in bed by
myself just laughing so hard thinking
about the idea of me making this Tick
Tock and then I woke up the next morning
and I made The Tick Tock and I got like
five million views and I and I don't
know it's it's kind of been that over
and over and over where it's like oh
like you have no reason to like get
emotionally involved in this or whatever
you can just [__] with people and troll
people and the end result is that people
don't really know what was real and what
wasn't real because there was like
little parts of it yeah nobody respected
a lot of trolling like a lot of like you
know like you said like like that video
you're talking about like when you're
like you're banned from L.A how about
that you're bad for my wife's vagina
yeah it was just like okay all right
well uh but but it but like you said it
worked and like I would also want to
like because obviously
is there has there has there been any
real world
complications because we I mean I I
don't believe I mean anything we see on
the internet I don't really look too
much into because you've kind of
mastered the internet right right has
there been an actual any like real world
complications in terms of
the attention like has it made it harder
for Linda to do certain stuff how does
her family feel about everything like is
I mean our families are really cool
about it in the sense that our families
have never mentioned the porn thing to
either of us ever ever wait wait wait
never never like
like your whole time being together it's
never gotten brought up I'll hear about
some [__] here and there like I'll hear
about oh my mom said something to my
sister about it and like asked her a
question about like oh why is Adam on
the cover of this you know website or
like why did why did the New York Post
post about Adam buying a Lamborghini
which is not not real you know a lot of
even my close friends thought that there
like a few people have come over my
house and been like where you keep the
Lamborghini I'm like oh yeah that video
well I wasn't gonna say that because you
would hit me and you were like hey man
you got some prop money
because I was gonna give her like 100
Grand or 200 Grand at the same time but
I couldn't find any prop money yeah
um but yeah no our families just don't
mention it they're just kind of too
polite it's kind of like the elephant in
the room a little like when you go to
the Armenian get-togethers it doesn't
get brought up at all no wow which is
crazy right like they just they're too
polite which thank God because I don't
want to [__] talk about that [__]
with them oh that's I'm just gonna one
word answer the [__] out of them if they
did try to bring it up to me or whatever
I'm just gonna laugh and roll with it
but yeah so there really hasn't been
anything too like like I mean obviously
you guys I mean you've always been kind
of famous like in the last seven years
eight years right it's been what 2015-16
is when you really started yeah I mean I
started November in 2015 and even before
that I had like 10 years of being this
very prominent BMX personality which
kind of like allowed me to get used to
but it's safe to say like six straight
years you've been kind of like a thing
on the you know where like my kid knows
who you are you know like looks like but
I would say now it's different right
definitely feels like we hit like a
different level of that and even today
we announced that we're doing this thing
that's like a a YouTube slash only fans
live stream where basically we're gonna
do a big 10 person podcast with a bunch
of porn stars and then in the other room
we haven't only fans live stream going
at the same time so it's basically going
to be like an orgy with a big group of
people and they're just swapping kind of
going back and forth in and out and like
the comments like like it just feels
like there's so much more attention on
everything that we do porn wise now but
at the the same time we also just have
this massive wave of hate with
everything we do too but like on Twitter
or Tick Tock getting comments and
getting hate is like one of the biggest
things that makes your [__] viral get
promoted so like I have random uh
Kendama Clips on my Tick Tock now that
have like three million views just
because like a couple thousand people
stopped in to say like haha you're a
cook or you know you're a piece of [__]
or you're you're a terrible parent or
whatever and I'm like okay well if I if
all I have to deal with is this and you
guys are going to make everything I do
go viral okay
there are certain things that are like
can you explain to me some of the
unwritten rules or code of the porn game
because you had shared some information
that we won't talk about off camera the
last time I saw you some details about
your video or Lena's video rather would
Jason love that we won't talk about but
there is a code right like and and I
think you said that Jason love maybe
broke the code a little I mean nobody
has ever explicitly told me that there's
a Code but I definitely feel like
there's an expectation that you keep it
a little bit gangster in terms of the
whole porn thing because if you're on
set you're going to see a lot of weird
[__] you know you're going to see dudes
having to jerk their dick off for 45
minutes to get hard you're gonna see
guys having a pop viagara to get hard
you're going to see you know girls who
have over there on their periods so they
have to go and like shove some [__]
sponge thing in there and to clean out
whatever kind of stuff might be in there
there's all kinds of [__] and like I
realize this because I like the one time
I did a anal threesome with Riley Reed
and my girl back in the day in our
backyard which is kind of hard to
imagine now we probably wouldn't do that
these days since we have like a family
and everything but you know there was
some some leakage some [__] flying you
know it's happened and you know I had a
turret on my knee at one point and stuff
and then I went on the podcast that week
and I just talked about it and my girl
had to tell me like yo like I don't
think girls are gonna necessarily want
to do anal threesomes with us if you're
just going to be airing out the grossest
things that happened and I was like that
is a really good point and so anything
like messy that happens on set I feel
like it's kind of
our responsibility to not talk about it
if a dude can't get hard it's like we're
not going to clown them we're just going
to kind of ignore it to me also probably
within the porn guy's code should be
like you don't like you know especially
if a [__] well-known dude like me is
gonna let you [__] their wife on camera
for porn content you should probably not
be critical of him in any way or you
might be respectful yeah you know don't
do this weird like dick comparison thing
or whatever even though obviously yeah
you have a huge hog but it's like you
just don't need to say that and I feel
like now if we shoot with any more guys
that will be very much a conversation
it's like okay this is the this is the
way that we can talk about this and this
is what we can and we need this you know
to stay on the same page in terms of all
this but I feel like he he got a lot of
hate for maybe not beating it up right
and that I I guess he probably had never
dealt with that before so he was
probably trying to compensate for that
by clarifying and like on your end
you're probably like thank you
I mean thanks for not like yeah you've
seen like some of these [__] scenes
This Guy's in he's [__] you know and
I thought about that after like oh wow
like I kind of got off easy there
because you know I didn't really think
about what kind of sex they were going
to be having beforehand and the the
scene that they did was very much like
very you know a a an easy entry point
for me in the sense that it was not some
Brian Gosling Hot Shot Hot Shot hookups
or whatever the [__] that is it's just
like the most aggressive type of porn
obviously so yeah I mean I guess he he
did kind of do me a favor in that regret
shout out to uh is he gonna come on the
podcast I don't know I don't know what
the [__] he's doing I heard he like flew
to Toronto to do six Buzz so who knows
what they're gonna ask him oh he's just
he's just he's he's probably this
probably raised his profile to like a I
mean he was already a pretty popular guy
I'm sure yeah but the weird thing in
porn is like you could be really popular
in porn and then you're still kind of
like a regular person to most people
right especially if you're a dude yeah
oh especially if you're a dude and even
like you know sometimes I think about
that like I can't get a little baby
interview I can't get a cardi interview
or Uzi vert interview but it's no
problem for me to get a savannah Bond
piece of content or Angela White or all
these like super huge girls are much
more approachable and like you know
humble than the top rappers you know
what um what is the like expectation now
moving forward is this is are you guys
gonna make her doing the dude scene a
regular thing we're definitely gonna do
more of it but I would say like the
frequency is probably the thing that's
kind of Up For Debate that we're still
kind of figuring out and like you know
there's some stuff that I really don't
mind at all like like I probably would
have been real nervous about it before
but like me [__] her with another guy
I don't really like feel any type of way
about that anymore like that's no
problem like I'll definitely do that
would you do the would you do the DP
yeah I feel like that's on the bucket
list but then that's like a dick on dick
yeah and you know it's like I'm not
gonna [__] a dude Kev listen I don't
want you to [__] dude but if you're
gonna do the DP there's no way that your
guys's dicks don't touch or ball slap or
just you're crossing swords I gotta do
it one time before I die okay and you
might I mean you got to do I mean
obviously you're married so it's got to
be with you my leg bumps another dude's
leg it's like whatever we all been in
the gym locker room before or whatever
but also like I don't know like it's got
to be a homie I think it's got to be
something I'm like real cool with would
you ever do anything with the transporn
star no
even if it was like [__] your wife
with a trans porn star
I don't feel like I want to turn our sex
life into a culture War thing you know
if I just
I'm not trying to like prove my wokeness
or anything and I [__] with a lot of
trans uh women and stuff like have had a
lot of them on the podcast I had Emma
Rose on the podcast I think I saw a
little bit of the uh you guys did like a
um a panel right it was like yeah yeah
and I got to meet a lot of really cool
trans people in that situation and
everything but my whole thing is like
I'm not really trying to do anything on
camera for money that I wouldn't want in
my private life as well yeah so like I
don't you know and even like I'll like
I'm not personally really like Mega
attracted to a BBW that's like 400
pounds right would I maybe do it on
camera like maybe yeah like that doesn't
so bad would you pop a Bluetooth
I might have to pop something I don't
know yeah my papa energy drink my papa's
C4 let's not give them any free [__]
publicity there all right that's why I
have their logo turned away from them
this guy's over here got the Celsius on
the floor
man we're over here drinking [__]
Energy Drinks like a couple of real
white guys like a couple of real Arizona
and New Hampshire white boys right
oh [__]